mais là la réforme que vous proposez et
une réforme qui consiste à payer les
professeurs en fonction des résultats de
leurs élèves s'est passé mckinsey qui a
proposé ça et je l'attendais celle-là
mais on est saisi du temps madame
je pense que ça peut être ça peut être
là franchement pour le coup ça peut être
je trouve que c'est profondément injuste
car vous savez très bien que selon
l'endroit où les professeurs professe où
il enseigne et bien les niveaux des
élèves ne sont pas toujours le même j'ai
accordé de 1000 euros tous les
professeurs qui sont en rade accord mais
ça veut dire que demain
souhaité et ils sont très mécontents et
ils ont raison d'ailleurs ce que vous
souhaitez c'est en réalité les pays en
fonction des résultats de leurs élèves
et puis en fonction de ce qui serait
capable de faire à côté d'ailleurs
regardez moi je souhaite les revaloriser
je le dis je souhaite les revalorisée de
3% par an en les faisant illusion de 16%
non car ils seront payés en plus pour
cette demi journée dans aux primaires le
mercredi matin non je ne joue pas ce
genre de choses mais
cette mesure ont été budgétés et donc ça
permettra si vous voulez d'avoir des
élèves qui sortent qui arrive en 6e en
maîtrisant la langue française ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui car il y à
20 % des élèves qui ne maîtrisent pas
les savoirs fondamentaux et ça
[Musique]